Now along the way,
you're going to run into bugs.
And these little critters are dead
set on breaking your app.
And much like cockroaches in Florida,
there's just no avoiding them.
There's going to be times in this
development process where your
code isn't going to work, and
you're not going to have any idea why.
And you're going to get
incredibly frustrated, and
you might even want to throw
your computer out the window.
Don't do that, seriously.
One tiny bug is not worth
thousands of dollars.
When I'm in these situations, I find
the best thing is to just walk away.
I mean, not forever, just for
like a few hours, or
maybe even a day, but
I go do something else.
I watch TV, or
I grab a drink with a friend, or go for
a run, or something to clear my mind and
take a mental break.
And I find that when I come back,
it's a lot easier to both find and
solve the problem that
I was having before.
Now, that's not the only way to deal
with these types of situations.
Let's go check back in with our pros and
see their advice for
dealing with bugs and
other issues in code.